please welcome Grammy and Academy Award  winning artist common and you say sighs  city what's up Chicago piece so Damian  Lillard has many personas to his family  he's just Dane to us fans we all know  Dane time and know what that looks like  and to his opponents in the league well  they know him as a serious problem yo  when I first heard for bar Fridays I was  like who is that this guy is nice on the  mic and I'm proud to present not only an  NBA all-star but this is an artist here  to do his thing this all-star Saturday  show some love to my god damn dollar  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  Oh  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  one more time for little Wayne  Jeremih Adam Blackstone and Dame Jalla